Don Eladio is a top dog in the Juarez
cartel he's the boss of the boss of the
boss and has the final say in basically
every matter
despite his very influential position
within the cartel
we aren't shown much of Don Eladio
throughout Breaking Bad and better call
Saul but of course a lot of you have
been asking for our video exploring Don
Eladio his life and money so she was
everything we know about the Greek
kingpin Don Eladio starting off with the
story
the earliest seen with Don Eladio is in
his meeting with Gustavo and max in 1989
Gus and Max has started a chicken
restaurant named los hermanos or the
chicken brothers but aside from chicken
they also wanted to get into the
up-and-coming market of methamphetamine
to accomplish this gus manipulates Don
Eladio into a meeting by giving out
samples of their product to Larios
henchmen in the actual meeting
Gus reveals that Donnell audio is simply
a middleman in the cocaine business for
Venezuela from this we can see at Don
Eladio is only in charge of the
transportation of cocaine into the
southwest of the US and not the
production itself despite max being a
biochemist and chemical engineer who
could produce a crystallized product
like glass
Don Eladio was still stuck on the fact
that Gus had manipulated him into a
meeting and ends up killing math as a
punishment this event occurs in 1989 and
considering that Don Eladio is already a
big shot given his house and ego it's
likely that he's been in charge of the
cartel for several years at this point
so both say about 10 years as far as we
know the Juarez cartel was founded by a
law do Juan Borgia and Hector Salamanca
would allow you being the leader given
that Don Eladio doesn't actually ever
leave Mexico it seems like he is in
charge of gonna do Venezuelans meanwhile
Hector employs essentially his entire
family to distribute the product within
New Mexico as for Don bolsa in Breaking
Bad
he too never leaves Mexico but this may
simply be as a result of eventually
partnering with Gus in Don bosses early
days he
have also been hands-on into a
distribution just like Hector moving on
this setup continues basically all the
way into Breaking Bad
as we see the cartel exclusively dealing
with cocaine even through the entirety
of season five a better call Saul it's
likely the transition into the meth
business is sometime during season six
of better call Saul as we know they're
already involved in meth trade by season
one of Breaking Bad so they make this
transition sometime between June of 2004
which is where season five better call
Saul ends and September 2008 which is
where season 1 or Breaking Bad picks up
will estimate that they get involved in
the meth business in the middle of this
time period and about July of 2006 I
asked for Gus's involvement in the
business in season three a better call
Saul we're showing Don Eladio being
pleasantly surprised with how much more
money Don bolsa is able to pull in with
Gus compared to Hector's income this
signals that Gus had just started
working for them as Don Eladio was not
used to this amount of money coming in
given that this takes place between
September 2002 and March 2003 it's
likely that Gus got involved with the
cartel and around the beginning of 2002
in the same meeting with Don Eladio
Hector tells Donal audio that he's
buying an ice cream shop to transport
cocaine across the border and it is
named a winking Greek inspired by Don
Eladio this shop doesn't last long
though as mike takes it down quite early
on and that's basically all the stages
of Don Loris Empire he starts the cartel
around 1980 and they carry out business
with cocaine and a stable rate up until
2002 at this point Gus and Hector both
up their distribution but only gutter
distribution lives on they continue with
this higher quantity of coke up until
mid 2006 and finally they switch over to
meth with Gus
until May 2009 when they all get killed
given this timeline let's estimate how
much money a Don Eladio would have made
starting off with the volume they were
moving in the first stage of the
business after Hector's ice-cream shop
is shut down he expects Gus to give him
a portion of his product we are shown
that Gus is able to bring in 12 packages
of cocaine per shipment
gusoff henchmen insists the hectare
should get five packages however not to
insist the hectare gets six or half the
shipment so it's likely that Hector was
able to smuggle in five packages per
shipment given that this is what Gus
thinks is Hector share this actually
makes sense
Don bolsa and Hector were probably
smuggling in ten packages per shipment
or five each but with the introduction
of Gus Don bolsa is able to smuggle in
12 packages per shipment himself thus
largely impressing Don Eladio with Gus's
distribution genius now we don't know
how much each of these packages weighs
or the frequency of Gus's shipments but
one clue we do get is how much money
Augustus able to give Don Eladio from
this shot it looks like Gus is able to
give three bundles of cash with six
watts per row with ten rows or about 180
wads of cash assuming that these are
each $10,000 wads Gus is able to give
one point eight million dollars and Don
Eladio every single month which shipment
software packages so with five packaged
shipments from each Don bolsa and Hector
they were bringing in 1.5 million per
month together now this amount likely
already accounts for all of Don bull and
Hector's cause and their cuts however
Don Eladio will still have to pay his
own henchman in Mexico and of course
that actual manufacturers themselves a
meaningful split between the
manufacturers and distributors would be
50/50 as both of them are equally as
integral to the business so about
750,000 were goodra manufacturers and
assuming that 20% goes Don Eladio
henchman Don Eladio would be left with
about 450,000 dollars a month or 5.4
million dollars per year with 22 years
in stage one of the business this was
put in a one hundred eighteen million
dollars for Don Eladio now of course
they probably had production issues here
and there and had to lay low in certain
periods of time so we'll call his profit
during stage one one hundred million
dollars as for stage 2 with the Gus
taking care of distribution
Gus was able to bring in 12 packages
upping the revenue to 1.8 million per
month with the Donnell audio retaining
30% of this he will get five hundred
forty thousand dollars
per month or 6.48 million per year with
this stage lasting four and a half years
this would bring another twenty nine
point one six million or about twenty
five million accounting for any issues
and finally ask for the last stage of
your business in the how much less Gus
fring make video we figured out that Gus
was moving about 100 pounds a week
before water and Jessie would get
involved with the super lab where they
would up at the two hundred pounds a
week and this would be the heyday of
Dario's business as at this point he
took over the production as they went
into the methamphetamine industry their
meth was going for $1,700 an ounce as
revealed by badger meaning that each
week Gus was able to pull in total
revenue of a whopping two point seven
two million dollars after accounting for
all of Gus's cost like distribution and
dealers cuts we determined in the Gus
fring video that he would have
approximately thirty percent of total
revenue to give to the cartel meaning
eight hundred sixteen thousand dollars
for Don Eladio per week assuming 20% for
the henchmen and thirty percent for his
cooks Don Eladio would get fifty percent
of the total cartel cut off from 30
percent by taking over production this
translates to four hundred eight
thousand dollars per week now
Gus cuts out Don Eladio about four
months before his own death which is on
July 14th 2009 so this set up will last
for approximately two years and nine
months coming out to fifty eight point
three four million dollars let's call it
50 accounting for issue is once again
this leaves Don Eladio with the total of
175 million or about 150 to 200 million
dollars so unfortunately
Don Eladio is not a billionaire at least
not from the deals we see however if he
controls many more segments across the
u.s. which is quite possible he would
easily cross the billion dollar mark
also given how much money agust makes
for Don Eladio
Don Eladio should just put his ego aside
for the very beginning as he would have
gotten 624 million dollars from Gus
alone during those 20 years between 1989
and 2009
given that max was a chemical engineer
and biochemist who could manufacture
top-notch meth but I guess it doesn't
matter has he made hundreds of millions
and lived a pretty long life anyways so
how much do you guys think Don Eladio is
worth comment that down below also if
you guys like the depth of this analysis
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one